7h50 germain treille ce matin votre
invité le député béarnais jean lassalle
qui est en ardèche aujourd'hui bonjour
jean lassalle bonjour d'abord il ya
cette loi macron ce 49,3 cette motion de
censure discuté aujourd'hui cette
majorité qui craque c'est si grave que
ça on est dans une crise de régime dans
une crise politique dans une crise
morale nous sommes en tout cas d'un
jeune dans une crise politique qui
traduit une crise
humaine
que nous ne savons plus gérer après la
crise économique qui s'est abattue sur
le monde depuis plus particulièrement
maintenant sur l'europe et la france
depuis quelques années déjà il ya eu la
crise économique sociale et maintenant
nous sommes dans la crise de la relation
humaine justement dans votre livre
témoignage qui s'intitule à la rencontre
des français c'est le récit de votre
marche effectuée il ya un peu moins de
deux ans les français vous ont-ils parlé
de la classe politique qui finalement ne
peut plus rien ou presque plus rien pour
eux ce sentiment d'abandon à sept
exactement mais toutes sensibilités
confondues et tout niveau social
confondues parce que ses parents ont
compris qu'on aurait dit il ya quelques
siècles que le tir l'état j'ai rencontré
des précédé préfet de région juin contre
des registres sans compter des grands
patrons de grands écrivains des artistes
sur un vendredi sur des chômeurs elle
est là
notre pays n'a pas connu depuis la
guerre tout le monde dit on vous déteste
pas sur vous j'avais aussi une caste qui
est l'om de noms qu'on ne fait même plus
remonté ce qu'on vous dit et vous ne
nous écoute et plus et des français avec
qui vous avez beaucoup échangé beaucoup
partagé ce sont leurs confessions leurs
états d'âme que vous avez recueillis
dans ce livre si vous deviez pour nous
pour france bleu drôme ardèche nous
racontait une rencontre très marquante
mais écoutez je ne plus te rrain cm je
vends de petites villes dans la rue
principale était très longue et tout
d'un coup dame bien sûr camper pleuvait
notablement avec son petit peu rempli
deux mois il est réputé qui marche je
vais mouiller dix vivant je suis venu
vous cracher à la figure vous êtes le
clown est celui qui se sert de la misère
pour se faire connaître pour se
promouvoir sa durée 40 minutes sur la
pluie des voiliers qui est deux bolides
ont une porsche devant ce que j'ai cru
être sa maison et visiophonie 10 10 un
petit bourgeois - au moins je fais
l'effort de venir jusqu'à toi moi je
comprends que tu m'en veuillent beaucoup
mais plus de 40 minutes pour me
l'expliquer et pour tout mélanger se
trouve que tu ne sais pas mieux que moi
et j'ai pu comprendre l'objet de sa
colère et quelques points toutes les
propositions qu'elle avait cette cascade
allait beaucoup et l'espoir aussi qu'il
animait c'est à dire que notre peuple
est aujourd'hui un peuple qui a peur
qu'il a plus confiance à un rien ni à
personne et qui recherche éperdue vent
d'espoir et il l'a montré suite à
l'impact de charlie vous êtes en ardèche
aujourd'hui quels souvenirs vous avez
gardez de votre passage dans la région
et goûter ce que j'ai retenu
c'est formidable attachement des
derniers habitants que j'ai rencontrés
dans les villages et les campagnes
souvent
l'éloigner mais pas tant que ça non plus
la fierté des hommes et des femmes que
j'ai pu trouver des amateurs de
désespoir absolu de certains d'entre eux
et à côté de ça des lueurs d'espoir
parce que le soir j'ai organisé des
réunions tous les deux autres soient
bien nous parlions et que
ces hommes et ces femmes se retrouver
des points communs ils croyaient être
séparés par le fait d'être de gauche ou
droite et sur les contreforts il était
déjà
répartis aux quatre coins sans aucune
relation entre mme après le passage d'un
tsunami
alors que il aspire à redevenir les
citoyens qui refonde le peuple le peuple
france jean lassalle le député du modem
qui marche à travers la france vous avez
discuté évidemment de ce que vous aviez
vécu avec des collègues parlementaires
avec des ministres avec même le
président de la république est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'avoir été
écoutés entendus et ce qu'on a pris
conscience finalement de ce qui se
passait sur le terrain dans le pays et
partout j'ai fait commettre cet état des
lieux je lui ai dit j'espère que nous
avons les moyens de saisir l'évolution
de notre peuple mais enfin je pense
qu'il faudrait le faire parce que il
semble que nous sommes vraiment à la
veille d'une révolution très gave on ne
peut pas dire j'étais très tendue on
veut pas dire que je continue à toutes
les sommes dues puisque mon livre n'est
absolument pas mis en valeur par les
médias parisiens comme si ce que je
lisais avec d'un côté un peu dérangeant
et si vous voulez être dérangé le livre
s'intitule à la rencontre des français
aux éditions du cherche midi jean
lassalle vous êtes à aubenas cet après
midi et ce soir pour une séance de
dédicaces et une réunion publique merci
beaucoup d'avoir été l'invité de france
bleu drôme ardèche bonne journée à vous
écouter versé à vous et je reçois pas
toutes et à tous une très très belle sur
le net